hello and welcome to the final safety
ridge on sunday of the season before
parliament breaks for the summer
next week
and i have to say since coming back from
maternity leave it has been an absolute
roller coaster exactly two weeks ago
teresa's coffee was in the studio
defending the prime minister about what
he knew when about allegations over the
behaviour of the former deputy chief
whip chris pincher well since then boris
johnson has announced his resignation
and we're now in a full-blown leadership
race
or we can introduce on that note our
first guest uh dominic raab has endorsed
sunak to be the next uh prime minister
he's backing his former cabinet
colleague who is currently the front
runner in the campaign uh rishi soon as
says inflation needs to be brought down
before taxes can be cut he's also
accused his rivals of spreading fairy
tales about the economy uh dominick rob
deputy prime minister joins us now thank
you very much for being uh with us
um before we get on to the race i'm just
keen to talk about the heatwave quickly
it's something that so many of our
viewers can be thinking about whether
you've got kids at school whether you're
communicating to work how concerned
should we be and what preparations are
in place i think being
prepared is the the best
resilience if you like i know that the
nhs are doing a whole load of
contingency planning that's actually
their stock in trade they're well
prepared for that kit malt house at the
cabinet office is making sure the other
preparations are in place obviously
there's some common sense practical
advice we're talking about stay
hydrated stay out of the sun at the
hottest times uh sun cream and those
sorts of things but we'll uh uh we ought
to enjoy the sunshine and actually we
ought to be resilient enough through
some of the pressures that we'll place
would it be smart for some people to
work from home
look that's for employers to uh to
consider him for people to decide i'm
not going to start dictating things like
that but obviously we've got more
flexible working it's one of the things
after the pandemic lots of businesses
are doing um so that will also help with
this kind of thing and how about parents
as well who might be concerned about
their kids going into school and do you
think it would be fair enough for them
to keep them at home for a couple of
days i think i mean look we're coming to
the end of uh
the the school term anyway but i think
making sure
young children
get the education they need is really
important particularly after the
pandemic um and the schools are well
placed to deal with that okay right
let's talk about the leadership ray
shall we and also more widely the
political situation over the last few
weeks been extraordinary
obviously rishi sunak is your preferred
candidate but just to rewind a bit um
you know when other ministers were
resigning or telling boris johnson that
he needed to go it was reported that you
were loyal to the pm to the end is that
accurate yes i mean look i give my
council as deputy prime minister and as
a cabinet member privately um and but
but i did want to uh avoid a leadership
contest and i did want to support the
prime minister but he lost the support
of the parliamentary party and once that
happens i think you look forward and we
try and and actually the one thing about
our system is it will resolve this
relatively swiftly by first week of
september and you've got to look forward
and that's politics uh you see it's
relatively swiftly by the 5th of
september some would say that actually
it's still quite a long time that boris
johnson is still in post
did you have any conversations about
potentially taking over as it can take a
pm
as you're obviously deaf to and pm
no um it was much discussed of course if
it had been ultimately necessary i would
have been willing to do it but i think
it's the right thing and it's also what
we've done in the past when the prime
minister has had to step down to allow
them to continue until the new leader is
in place so it wasn't seriously
considered at any point then i think it
would have depended on effectively what
mps as a whole would have wanted but i
think once the pm made clear he would
step down i think the push
for an immediate
resignation and walking away from number
10 i think that went away how did you
find boris johnson in those weeks well
do you know what the one of the things
about him is i think he's uh very
magnanimous uh he uh clearly was
disappointed but got on with uh the the
process of making sure the government is
still stable looking at what more we can
do in the weeks
ahead to make sure that we consolidate
the
achievement and keep the delivery going
whether it's on the cost of living
particularly which people are concerned
about so i think he was focused on doing
the job i mean
clearly a very difficult time for him um
i'm quite interested because you
obviously you know
you say that you were like loyal to the
prime minister to the end but you've
decided to back russia sunak in the
context who many people in your party
believe was really the driving force
forcing him from office when he resigned
why
well they just don't accept that account
but the reason i'm supporting rishi
sunak and i said one thing about
leadership contest it forces you to look
at the future is that he is i think far
and away the best
place with the experience and the
caliber to see us through the cost of
living challenge i think he's the one
with a credible economic plan to get
inflation down if we can't do that we're
not going to leave people with the money
in their pockets from tax cuts or
anything else so controlling inflation
but then driving forward and he set out
some further ideas about boosting uh
through deregulation smarter regulation
the pharmaceutical sector the tech
sector the financial sector uh financial
services sector today i also um think
he's got the right values which is i
think uh what you're touching on i mean
i've known rishi since he first became a
member of parliament um the the values
that he grew up with of hard work family
entrepreneurialism i know the story i've
heard it privately let alone in the
course of these leadership
debates and hustings about how when his
mum was running the pharmacy he would
help her do the books he understands if
you like that pocket book economics
which i think is so important at time
the cost living and thirdly let's
remember what this is ultimately about
in two years the general election and
the polling shows he's far and away the
strongest candidate to beat kiss stammer
we'll definitely dissect some of those
things uh later but just on
boris johnson loyalty question you know
others who did stand by boris johnson
have ended up rowing in behind liz trust
nadine doris for example jacob rees-mogg
who said that rishi sunex showed
disloyalty
according to the papers boris johnson
wants anybody but rishi sunak to be
prime minister did you talk to the prime
minister about your decision to back him
so of course there's a courtesy i want
to make sure the pm knew before um i've
talked to him since i've not heard any
of those kind of things from him but of
course there'll be a circle of advisers
and people who want to back this will
make these points i'm going to adhere
meticulously to reagan's 11th
commandment and not speak ill of my
fellow conservatives and actually might
be the only person in this contest well
i
i mentioned it during the referendum of
trying to play the ball not the man or
the woman and i'm going gonna do it
again but look i think people want a
positive prospectus and i think rishi on
those three critical things economic
plan uh values and uh frankly
electability ability to reach out not
just within the conservative party but
to the country whether it's blue wall or
red wall seats he's the guy that can win
at the end of the day i think that's
pretty important uh factor in all of
this well let's talk about the economic
policy at shall we you know richie
sununic always says that he is someone
who believes in low taxes but if we just
look at his record i think we should be
able to show
um some of that on the screen now and
because he raised taxes this is the uk
tax changes for different chances as you
can see
along the bottom there um everything
above the line is raising taxes overall
below the line is the tax changes that
would lessen the burden you can see
there that rishi sunak raised taxes the
same amount in two years as gordon brown
did
in 10. he says he believes in low taxes
but we've got to look at his record it
points to a bit of a different story
well i think the the the elephant in the
room is caused the pandemic and we had
the biggest
economic contraction in 300 years and
then all the pressures of getting the
nhs back on track um i don't think
anyone none of those other uh chances
had to deal with that and very
interestingly all of the other
conservative chancellors who have
commented uh have said that actually
he's the one with the credible economic
plan but we want to get taxes i
absolutely accept the pandemic is is
something that came along and you have
to respond to but there are choices
there too you can raise taxes you can
also cut spending and go back to
austerity which rissy sunix said he
didn't want to do or you can look at
borrowing so there are political choices
here too well you can't borrow your way
out of an inflation crisis and if people
are suggesting that we should make cuts
to the nhs at a time not just of kovi
but with all of the other non-covered
nhs challenges they've got to spell out
where they're coming from what rishi has
done is say look we need to get
inflation under control he has cut
national insurance the biggest tax cut
in a decade for for payroll 330 pounds
for a typical worker but what he's not
going to do and it's important to
explain why is cut taxes when actually
you'll be taking we want to all leave
people with more money in their pocket
but if you cut taxes and then inflation
robs people of that money because it's
worthless or sees interest rates go up
so their mortgages are more expensive
then frankly it's uh it's a it's a false
economy and i think rishi is the one
that is credibly stating until we
control inflation is the only one saying
this we're not going to be able to
deliver those other things and he's also
the one that's talking about the
long-term plan to strengthen investment
by taking a different approach
regulatory-wise he's talked about this
today tech pharmaceuticals
financial services areas of great
comparative advantage to the uk economy
so from the immediate challenge to the
long-term prospectus i think he's the
one with the plan liz trust says that
actually cutting taxes leads to growth
she said in the telegraph this morning
that a continuity economic policy under
who she could be talking about there has
led to low growth for decades
liz can answer for her policies and her
record she was chief secretary of the
treasury um people can see where the
spending and head count in the civil
service went up or down that's for them
to work out but what i just say this is
the immediate challenge what people are
worried about right now what do you mean
about the civil service
well
it's not just uh rishi that is going to
be accountable for what he's done in the
face of a massive pandemic but this has
done was chief secretary of the treasury
i mean did she cut taxes at that time
did spending go up or down during her
period as uh cst i think without without
criticizing her personally i think it's
right that everyone on their record is
is scrutinized so what is the record
well you can go and look it up but i
want to focus on what rishi is saying
and what we're uh and what his team uh
uh backing him uh have been attracted to
it is the idea that sensible
conservative economics means you get
inflation down if not any money that is
delivered to people in their bank
accounts through tax cuts will be robbed
again through inflation or interest
rates uh and mortgage payments going up
that can't be right we've got to get
inflation down and then and of course
he's talked about come 2024 pending off
the basic rate of income tax when it is
sustainable um
other candidates are saying that they
believe some of the tax cuts they're
promising can be self-funding uh penny
morgan for example wants to halve the 80
on fuel on paper that will cost 13
billion pounds her team tells sunday
times it would actually be self-funding
because drivers would end up buying more
fuel
i i you know i'd like to see a serious
analysis of self-funding tax cuts
sometimes it can have that effect if
you're generating um more business
activity that's why for example what
rishi did with the super deduction on
capital allowances encourages business
investment that can encourage greater
revenue but but i don't think those
alternative suggestions are particularly
credible and of course the big question
is what impact would it have on
inflation until we've got inflation down
any money that is handed out with one
hand will be taken back with the with
with the other and i think you can see
that when we had the debate uh on friday
night and richie explained that
people understood that and you can see
from all the polling that people feel
that he's the one leveling with the
country about the challenges we face but
also offering a credible well thought
through plan to get through it you talk
about the polling and i know that you're
referring to polling of the general
public but i just want to talk about
polling and party members because it
does feel uh like actually when it comes
to party members he's not the favorite
choice uh is he i think we have a look
at some of uh the uh hugo poll for
example so this is the kind of most
recent serious uh weighted poll of um
conservative party members they were
asked which of the following candidates
do you most want to replace boris
johnson this was earlier this week
penny mordant
way out in front of rishi sunak well i
think if you look in the con home had
some other polling today uh it is quite
fluid but the reason i'm pointing he
doesn't top that one either though does
it well actually it's very close but of
course uh i think the more people hear
from rishi and the more the choice is
presented i think the more compelling it
gets but ultimately this isn't just you
can just make this final point it's not
just a question for conservative mps or
indeed conservative members it is a
question for the country and i think
conservative members who will make this
decision will be focused particularly
when we get to the last round on who is
best placed to win over voters whether
they remain or leave swing voters labor
voters or soft conservative voters in
the shires in the uh the working class
blue wall seats as well as the red wall
seats and ultimately it is very clear in
the jail jail polling uh jail partner
poland shows very clearly rishi sonak is
the only one that can win but it's not
general election is it is this is this
is kind of this is about concerning
party members and actually if you look
at the hugo poll yeah every one of the
head-to-heads which is effectively loses
like steve baker told me uh this week
that whoever goes up against russia
sooner in the head-to-head will win well
i don't think that's right and the
reason being first of all it's very
fluid the member spoiling secondly the
members are ultimately one of the
factors uh of the the consideration
would be who can actually win in two
years time but general election and
there the the the gap is clear only
risks you can win the others are 10 12
points behind so when you ask the
country and this ought to be an outward
looking
contest or at least perspective
they they see that rishi can win from
the north to the south leave seats
remain seats and that's what ultimately
this will be about and i'm very
confident members will focus on that in
the last round um now four of the five
candidates who are still in the race
have committed to doing the sky news
debate on tuesday night the one who
hasn't so far as rishi sunic so will he
commit to doing it i'll let the campaign
team give you uh
an answer on that i don't know uh what
the schedule is but uh look at what i
think he'd be very confident going into
uh all these debates i think he uh sean
uh in the channel four debate i'm sure
he will again this evening but you
accept the importance of these debates
because you know as you have been saying
as well you know it's not just about the
conservative party members isn't it
we're electing the people are electing
the next prime minister oh look i don't
think rishi's shying away from that
scrutiny i think he's the the standout
performer in these debates of of the
candidates that are likely to win um so
uh but look at i don't know what the
schedule is and i'll let him uh and his
team answer that do you think whoever
wins should call an election to get
their own mandate
this is a mandate for the conservative
party it's important we deliver on that
and we'll have an election a couple of
years time i think the the country so no
basis i don't think that people i think
voters are going about their ordinary
business with the cost of living
challenges with the war in ukraine with
all the other things we're dealing with
i think they want a government in place
delivering for them and that's what i'm
sure will focus and so you don't see a
problem in say 160 000 or whoever many
conservative members choosing the next
prime minister look we had this debate
every time it wasn't a problem when
gordon brown took over it wasn't a
problem
when
uh theresa may uh took over and and it
won't be a problem uh in september okay
finally who actually nearly finally on
finally on the uh leadership question um
who do you think is risky soon it's
biggest rival
i don't want to get into come on
look they're all good candice i said i'd
adhere to reagan's 11th commandment i
think one of the things we've shown
actually in this contest is the breadth
of talent in the conservative party uh
you've got entrepreneurs you've got
people with armed forces experience and
i'm very proud that we've got a slate of
candidates diverse in all sorts of
different ways not just background but
also professional and and others now
very finely because i promised myself
that when i next interviewed you i am
going to ask you about this so i am
going to um
a few weeks ago you had a very lively
prime minister's question session with
angela rainer and right at the end
you seem to be giving a wink i think we
should be able to show wig i'm gonna
have to go now i've got a train to catch
[Applause]
she talks about working people
she talks about working people
[Applause]
what is going on there who were you
winking at i was winking at ian murray
who was by angie ray now by the way i've
got a sanji reigns great value in all of
these uh she's so so lively i mean it's
a quite a contrast with kier um but so
why were you ricky ian murray he and
murray
i find this to just ask more questions
well at pmq's you have these subplots
going on and he was sort of praying at
me uh from uh uh by angie's side and uh
um
i was winking at him uh but not least
because he was talking about i think
there was something uh that was said
about uh angela rayner standing in a
leadership contest against kyr and he
said what sort i think i heard him say
something like what's wrong with that um
so anyway uh it's all part of the cut
and thrust there you go uh thank you
very much glad that we did clear that up
so there you go dominic rav wicking at
air murray not angela rainey thank you
very much for being on the program today
uh